Hi, welcome back. In the last few
sessions, we've looked at patterns in
stock prices for momentum reversal that
suggests at least suggests that you
might be able to make money using past
prices. In this session, I want to look
at technical analysis. Broadly speaking,
technical analysis is built on using
past price patterns to predict future
prices. Increasingly, as we will see,
trading volume has become part of
technical analysis as well. So let's get
the show on the road. If you look at the
basis for technical analysis, here are
the things that stand out. Technical an
analyst believe that price is determined
solely by supply and demand. No, I
wouldn't disagree with it. Everybody
would agree with it. But technical
analysts also believe that value is an
abstraction that markets are not focused
on value. They're focused on mood and
momentum and what shifts it. So
technical analysis is all about
forecasting supply and demand and argues
that much of supply and demand might
come from irrational forces. Forces that
can cause stock prices to have the
patterns that you actually observe.
Detecting what that mood and momentum is
and detecting shifts in that mood become
the basis for almost all of technical
analysis. With that leadin, let me make
a two confessions. The first is I'm not
a chartist. I don't know enough about
technical analysis to use it well. But I
do know people who build their entire
investing strategy or let me put it
differently trading strategy around
looking at charts and technical
indicators.
The second confession I'm going to make
is there are hundreds and hundreds of
these chart charting patterns and
technical indicators and I don't have
the bandwidth or the knowledge to cover
them all. Most of these chart patterns
and tech and technical indicators though
come from making an assumption about
human beings being irrational investors
being irrational and that irrationality
feeding into stock prices. So rather
than try to cover all technical
indicators, an impossible task, or go
through them sequentially, I would like
to bucket technical indicators into
groups based on the behavioral
assumption that drives the use of that
technical indicator. I'm going to argue
that almost all technical indicators
fall into five buckets based on the
irrational irrationality that's at the
basis for that pattern, for that
indicator working. Let's start with the
first one. We talked earlier about
investor ration and one of the things
that stands out is maybe investors
overreact overreact to news especially
big news stories in either direction.
What does that mean? When good news
comes out, stock prices go up too much.
When bad news come out come out comes
out, stock prices drop too much. And if
in fact investors overreact, here's what
you should expect to see. Extreme
movements in stock price in both
direction should be followed by a drift
in the opposite direction. You say what
are you talking about? If stock prices
jump a lot, if investor overreaction is
the rule that drives markets, you should
expect to see prices come down in the
weeks after. If the stock price drops a
lot, you should expect to see stock
prices drift up. And the more extreme
the adjustment, the greater the
adjustment, the the initial drop or the
initial increase, the greater the
adjustment will be in the weeks
following.
Of course, you can push back and say
why, if this is the case, are there so
few true contrarian investors in the
market. We'll look at some reasons why
might they they might not be. The second
question, this is a more generic
question about markets, is why are
markets more efficient about
incorporating some types of information
than other types of information. With
that leading though, if investors
overreact, there are some technical
indicators and patterns that you can use
to detect that overreaction.
One is to look at odd lots. I know this
is a throwback in time, but there was a
time when if you bought seven shares or
10 shares, you did not buy shares in
round lots. Round lots were 100 shares
or thousand shares, you paid more in
transactions costs. It's a throwback in
time because as trading has become
easier, the oddlot trading effect has
also dropped off. When oddlots were part
of the game, there were analysts or
investors who looked at the proportion
of trading that was coming from oddlot.
And here's the leap they made. Oddlot
trading comes from small investors.
Small investors at least in their
telling are more likely to overreact and
do rational things. So if a significant
amount of oddlot trading is is in the in
the form of buys, you're going to sell
the stock. If a significant of oddlot
trading is sells, you're going to buy
the stock. You're pushing against
whatever the conventional wisdom is. The
second indicator looks at institutional
investors because institutional
investors can also be irrational. Here
you look at cash positions held by
mutual funds. Most mutual funds are
required to invest in equities. That's
all they're allowed to do. They can go
long on stocks, but they can't hold
anything else. But what if you're a
mutual fund manager, an equity mutual
fund manager who believe stocks are
overpriced? You know what mutual funds
do? They hold cash then. And the
argument that technical analysts would
make is when mutual funds hold a lot of
cash, they're being bearish about the
future. But here again you have to think
like a contrarian. If you assume that
mutual funds are generally wrong, they
overreact. When they get bearish, you
get bullish. So you basically buy shares
when mutual fund cash positions rise and
you sell shares when they drop below
what a typical or a norm is. The third
is investment advisory opinion. Again,
over time, investment advisor can be
bullish or bearish. And if you're a
contrary, if you if you believe that
investors overreact, here's what you're
going to do. As investor investment
advisors become more bullish, they tell
you that stocks are going to go up, you
turn more bearish, you do the opposite.
The assumption again is investment
advisor overreaching. They overreact to
whatever is happening in the market. So
the first group of technical indicators
are built on the presumption that
investors overreact and essentially to
give you the tools to detect when that
happens and to act in the opposite
direction. Take the second group of
indicators. The second group of
indicators goes to the core of the mood
and momentum argument. The argument here
is that stock prices go up and down.
There are but they're driven by mood and
momentum more than fundamentals. So your
job as a trader then is to detect what
that mood is but more critically detect
when the mood is shifting. So there are
whole host of indicators that try to
detect when mood shifts happen. So let's
take a look at a few of them. One is the
breadth of the market. What is the
breadth of the market? On any given day
when you look at what the market did
that day you're going to see the market
was up or the market was down. But if
you take a closer look, sometimes
markets can be up because a few stocks
went up a lot. In other words, it's not
as if the bulk of stocks went up, but
only 30% of stocks went up, but they
went up by enough that the overall
market went down. That's a market with
no breath. In contrast, if you have a
market advance, but most stocks go up,
you have a market with breath. You're
saying, "Who cares?" In the moodshifting
world of technical analysis, when you
have a market with no breath, even if
it's going up, you have to take the
opposite position. A market with no
breath in either direction has no
conviction. If no conviction, you view
it as an advanced indicator that the
mood is going to shift. The second is
support and resistance lines. As long as
charts have been around, these have been
around. I'm going to show you a picture
in the next know in a couple of minutes.
But basically this argu the argument
support and resistance lines. You take a
stock or even the overall market
there's a upper bound for prices and a
lower bound. You're saying how do you
come up with the upper and the lower
bound by looking at history. If you hit
the upper bound the ex the assumption is
you're going to come back down. if
you're at the lower bound that you're
going to come back up, but once in a
while you might break through the line.
What does that mean? You go through the
upper bound and keep going up. That is
viewed as a mood shift potentially. And
here's where the contradiction comes in.
For some traders, that could be a
bullish sign. We'll talk about the
argument for that. And for other
traders, it can be a bearish sign. The
third group of technical indicators are
moving averages. Technical analysts love
moving averages. is smooth out prices.
What is a moving average price? Rather
than look on daytoday what stock price
are doing, you look at a 60-day average
for prices and you look at what the
current price is and whether it's above
the moving average line or below the
moving average line. Again, how you view
it will depend on what you think is an
indicator of a mood shift and you base
it on that. And finally, you look at
trading volume shifts.
In addition to prices changing, trading
volume can change over time. So if you
have an extended period where trading
volume is low, you might view it as a
signal of a potential mood shift coming.
So let's take support and resistance
lines by itself. You know, if you look
rationally, you're saying who cares
whether a stock breaks through a $100
price or 120 or $50 through. So
basically from a rational perspective,
there is no basis for support or
resistance lines. But let me give you a
spin where they could potentially feed
back and affect prices. I call this a
price feedback loop. I'll tell you a
positive story where you break through
the resistance line. You break through
the resistance line. The positive story
is you're going to draw in fresh
investors, investors with FOMO, fear of
missing out, and that will push the
stock price up. So there are some people
who argue that when a stock price breaks
breaks through a resistance line, it is
in fact going to continue to go up. At
the same time, there are other traders
who view exactly the same event and say
that's not good. If you break through
the resistance lines, people are going
to pay attention to you and people pay
attention to you. That's a bad thing. If
you're an overpriced stock and your
stock price will come down. One of the
things you're going to notice about
technical indicators, the same indicator
can send different signals to different
traders depending on how they view that
indicator.
The third group of technical indicators
that I'm going to talk about are
indicators that I call momentum
indicators. At the basis for these
indicators is the assumption that
investors take time to learn. What does
that mean? when good news comes out the
price might go up but it won't go up
enough because investors are still
learning and prices will then continue
to go up in the weeks after. So this is
the exact opposite of the investors you
know overreact story but investors learn
slowly. Conversely there's bad news the
price drops but it's not done. It'll
continue to drift down. There is some
evidence and we'll talk more about this
that there are drifts after good news
and bad news announcements. So that the
story can point to those that evidence
say look it's true but let's look at the
indicators that you might use if you
believe that investors learn slowly.
Perhaps one of the most widely used
technical indicators is relative
strength. Sounds complicated but here's
what you do in relative strength. You
take the current price and divide by the
price 6 months ago or a year ago
depending on the period over which you
want to measure the relative strength.
That ratio of current price to price 6
months ago then becomes your measure of
relative strength. The higher that
number, the more momentum there is in
the stock. The lower that number, the
more negative the number, you're getting
momentum in the other direction.
So here's what a momentum indicator
would suggest you to do. that you buy
stocks with high relative strength that
have gone up the most. A variant on
relative strength is to look at trend
lines where you draw a chart and you
draw a line through the chart. If it's
upward sloping, you got a stock with
positive momentum. If it's downward
sloping, you got a stock with negative
momentum. Again, the period over which
this chart is drawn can vary across
traders leading to the same stock having
a positive trend line with one trader
because they looked at the last 6 months
and a negative trend line for another
trader who's been looking over the last
two years. But relative strength and
trend lines are momentum indicators and
increasingly momentum indicators are
supplemented with trading volume
analysis. Here's the reason. And this is
a chart we looked at earlier in this in
this class. It's a chart that looks at
how strong momentum is as a function of
trading volume. And it finds that the
higher the trading volume, the greater
the momentum effect. So by bringing
moment trading volume into your
technical analysis, you're strengthening
your momentum story. So investors
overreact, investors learn slowly. you
know, contrary views of the world, but
it's completely okay. And you could
argue that both have some evidence out
there to back them up. And the third, of
course, is detecting shifts in demand
and supply through looking at charts and
looking at trading volume. The fourth
group of technical indicators are
indicators built around the presumption
that some investors are smarter than
other investors. It's built on the
presumption that there is smart money
out there. Who goes into the smart money
pile? Might be hedge funds in some case
might be names Warren Buffett or Peter
Lynch. And what do you do? You try to
track what they do and then you try to
follow them. So it's a it's a flip side
of the contrarian approach where you did
the opposite of what institutional
investors were doing. Here you focus on
a subset of those investors because you
think they're smart and you try to learn
what they're doing and you try to do the
same thing.
So let's look at some indicators that
have been around that track smart
investors. One is specialists. This is a
throwback in time again when trading
happened on the floor of the exchange
and you had specialists who basically
specialized in individual stocks. They
managed the trading in that stock. The
argument was that those specialists knew
more about what was coming to the stock
than the rest of us. So the people who
track what specialists did, especially
if they sold short on a stock and then
they would argue they must know that
something bad's happening and try to
imitate them. We'll talk more about
insider buying and selling later in this
class, but insiders are directors,
managers. You could argue they know more
about the company than the rest of us.
So if they're buying, that's good news.
You follow them and you buy as well. and
they're selling. It's bad news and you
sell as well. Increasing with social
media now and with the amount of
information we have, we can track what
smart investors are buying, selling,
holding. There are no entire set of
indicators, you know, that track what
Warren Buffett has been buying even
though the man is 93 years old and you
try to buy the same things. implicit in
all of these indicators, the assumption
of smart money and trying to track what
smart money is doing.
The final group of technical indicators
I'm going to put under a category that
might sound like um you know that I'm
trying to set it aside, but I'm not.
These indicators believe that markets
are controlled by external forces,
forces that are outside our control. And
I'm going to call them mystics. So you
will see these these the these technical
indicators where you'll see charts over
not just a year or two years but over
hundreds of years and the argument here
is markets go through these waves that
stretch over time and there's nothing
you can do to fight them. One is called
the Elliot way which you know where
where you look at markets over centuries
and you argue that these waves have been
around forever and they will come back
to drive what prices do. There's also
the Dow theory where the market is
always considered as having three
movements all happening at the same
time. There's a narrow movement
daytoday, there's a short swings
monthtomonth and the third is a movement
that stretches over years and much of
this is out of your control. Fighting it
is futile. You basically have to go
along.
All in all, technical indicators stretch
the spectrum because they're built
around different assumptions about
irrationality.
So, as I said, there are people out
there who build their entire
trading/investing
around technical indicators. Who am I to
say that they they don't work? But if
you decide to go this route and use
technical analysis, charting, I have
five suggestions. First is find out the
behavior or come up with it on your own.
You might not be able to find it
somewhere out there, but you can reason
through it. What is the irrationality,
the behavioral quirk on which this
technical indicator is built? What are
you trying to take advantage of? Second,
when somebody tells you that a charting
or a technical indicator works, just
don't trust them. Verify it. Take a look
at the data. It's actually very
difficult to trust hazy patterns or very
very complex patterns. But some of the
simpler patterns like support and
resistance lines, you can use the data
to see if it actually works. The third
is even if you find a technical
indicator that works for you, you need
to trade on a timely basis. This is not
the kind of trading where you can find a
buy based on a tech technical indicator
and wait a week to buy it. You got to
buy it instantaneously. Execution is key
and keeping your trading cost down while
you execute in a timely way is a tough
trick to pull off, but you got to pull
it off. The fourth is and you probably
noticed this as we've talked about price
patterns is price patterns are very
time-sensitive. What does that mean? You
got momentum over 6 months. You got
reversal over 5 years. You have to have
a time horizon that's almost goldilocks
in the sense that you got the right time
horizon for the indicator you pick. You
overh hold or you underhold, you won't
make the money. And fifth, when you're
when you're a trader, you are going to
have a lot of trading over the course of
the year. You might trade three, four,
five times your portfolio because you're
buying and selling on a almost on a
continuous basis. It is key at the risk
of stating the obvious that you keep a
control on your trading cost. So you got
to think about, you know, what we talked
about in the context of trading costs,
bid ass spreads, you know, price impact,
the cost of waiting, and weigh them all
in and find a way to keep them under
control. And if you can do that and make
money on charts and technical
indicators, all the more power to you. I
hope you found this session useful and I
thank you very much for listening.